why are kitchens covered in foil
ah
[Music]
hi my name is sarah hi my name is tiki
segura hi my name is yoni segura i'm 24
i'm from los angeles california and i'm
a persian orthodox jew i'm from los
angeles i'm an orthodox jew and i'm
married with two kids and asked my
buzzfeed to come in and discuss what
orthodox jews believe what do orthodox
jews believe you know orthodox judaism
is more of an umbrella term for people
who believe in the written and oral
torah god gave us the torah on mount
sinai through moses the torah tells us
how to live our lives there's the
written law and then there goes along
with that the oral law people often
think this is somehow less important no
command given in the torah can be
followed correctly based on the written
law if you went to a doctor and he said
yeah i know how to do this brain surgery
i've got this book here you want to go
anywhere near that guy he's went to med
school he learned from someone who
showed him how to do it he's practiced x
amount of times you got the oral as well
as the written knowledge as to how to do
anything so then people wonder well how
do you know that it's not just
someone's interpretation there are
actually set methodical legal principles
13 actually which you can use to figure
out exactly what's going on
why do orthodox jews wrap their arms
so it says in the torah you the total
that there should be these things that
are in between your eyes and on your arm
it's customary for orthodox jewish men
to wrap their arms with what is called
to fill in there's actually a verse
which is repeated four times in the
torah which says that you have to you
have to put these boxes with straps on
your arm and on your head there's these
little boxes and inside of it it has the
text of shema and it has a text of the
actual commandment it's a physical
reminder to have god on their mind and
close to their heart binding your
actions and your mind to the service of
god is often something that i've heard
but at the end of the day the reason we
do any of the commandments is because
it's a commandment from the torah
whether it's why we kosher whether it's
why one gives charity even it's
incredibly important to help people into
care but the reason that you have to is
because the torah says so there's a
statutory obligation to do so why do
orthodox jewish women cover their heads
one of the things that we believe is
that when a woman gets married her hair
is one of like almost like a nakedness
married women will customarily cover
their heads with either a head scarf or
a wig it's more to symbolize that
element of privacy and modesty i
sometimes you know will wear different
hair coverings right now i'm wearing a
wig which is a way of dressing modestly
why do orthodox jews rock when they pray
that's an interesting question i think
the true answer is because that's what
they see growing up when you're praying
you're supposed to be you know very
present and focused in the moment it can
help you kind of like with muscle memory
get into a certain head space you can
stand still it's whatever helps you
focus it's a way of getting kind of in
that mindset of i'm talking to god you
know the way i think about it anyway one
is standing in front of the creator or
however you want to think of god there's
certain trepidation or shaking that goes
with that you get they get into it it's
like physical too
do orthodox jewish couples kiss
i guess the short answer is yes you know
they kiss orthodox jewish couples once
they are married have a normal romantic
life i guess i would say first time i
kissed my wife was after we got married
the basic idea is that what's called is
chaumer negia which literally means
guarding touching before marriage we
don't touch each other in any shape or
form you just like raise your eyebrows
like oh that's weird right you know
everyone's at their level of observance
but yeah i usually generally save that
as something to be done under the
context of marriage what is kosher
kosher is a set of laws which dictate
what you can and cannot eat we don't mix
meat and milk together in any shape or
form whether it's cold or hot fruits and
vegetables need to be washed checked for
bugs because we don't eat bugs we don't
eat pigs animals have to chew their cud
and have completely split hooves with
fish they have to have scales and fins
we don't eat shellfish food has to be
prepared by a jew and you can just be
involved in the cooking of it so you'll
find that at most kosher restaurants
there's going to be someone on site who
lights the fires or is involved in some
part of the cooking process the food
that we eat generally in the store is
you'll find little symbols on the foods
food picked up from a kosher restaurant
will have a double seal on it they're
just going to be in a bag which is tied
and then there's going to be a sticker
around it kosher food isn't blessed by a
rabbis often a misconception that people
have
why are kitchens covered in foil alright
so kitchens are not commonly covered in
foil there are certain types of
materials which can be made kosher in
certain materials that cannot be made
kosher if a kitchen is not kosher
they'll sometimes cover the countertop
as opposed to going through the process
of making everything kosher again what
is shabbat
shabbat starts on sundown on friday
night lasts about 24 hours until after
the stars come out on saturday night
you're not allowed to do anything which
is constructive work something which
once you do it it can't be undone easily
so you can't cook you can drive things
like that there's no distractions on
shabbat there's no working there's no
playing with your phone there's no
calling anyone especially nowadays when
everyone's so connected the time to
really just disconnect and focus on your
relationship between each other and
between god when i've had a medical
emergency happen to me it's a surreal
experience to quote unquote break the
sabbath to save a life but that is what
you're supposed to do human life trumps
all of those things do orthodox jews
ever marry cousins
it does happen occasionally it's
technically not one of the forbidden
relationships uh it's a bad idea
genetically going back to pre-war europe
jews lived in small little villages and
there weren't always that many people to
choose to marry sometimes your only
option of someone to marry outside of
your siblings would be a cousin but it's
not common anymore i don't think people
look at it as a great idea do orthodox
jewish couples sleep in separate beds
yes and no
there's different times of the month
when a woman has her period and it's
called a time of knee death the couple
will separate for that period of time
but then you know the rest of the time
they can do whatever they want so that
would be five days of her period and
then we count another additional seven
days that are considered like clean days
almost after that period of time a woman
can go to the mikveh which is a ritual
bath and at that point she and her
husband can venture a bed together it's
a new like fresh restart to a marriage
every single month
are orthodox jewish marriages arranged
uh
when you say arranged that can mean many
different things to many different
people you can meet a potential spouse
through a blind date a matchmaker dating
app however you'd like in some circles
parents will often arrange a meeting
however they both have to consent my
wife and i were set up to go out but we
went out we saw if we liked each other
did and we decided to get married who's
best to set you up people who know both
parties would know hey maybe these two
will get along arranged marriages
no
i think when people think of orthodox
judaism who haven't been exposed to
they're gonna go to like what's in the
media usually what's portrayed in the
media is going to be tilted to an
extreme one way or the other i don't
think that's always accurate we're a
diverse group we come from different
backgrounds you know we often get lumped
together with people who have negative
experiences with orthodox judaism i've
always loved living my life the way i do
living as an orthodox jew you know we're
we're normal people
[Music]
you